Kameron voices mom Libby is breaking her
silence following her son's unexpected
death the 20-year old Disney Channel
star died from a seizure in his sleep on
July 6 his family later told ET that he
suffered from epilepsy Libby took to
Instagram on Saturday to share this
sweet black-and-white photo of her son
hugging her saying quote he is my
compass Cameron's father sister and
descendants co-stars Sophia Carson and
dove Cameron are among the many who have
spoken out in the wake of Cameron's
death Disney Channel announced The
Descendants three premiere planned for
July 22nd was cancelled oh don't you
ever miss screaming at people and just
making them run away from you you're
thinking of my mother and I was usually
on the other end of that so not really
no Cameron was known for starring in
several Disney Channel projects
including The Descendants franchise
where he played the role of Carlos the
son of Cruella De Vil et spoke with
Cameron in 2017 weeks before the second
Descendants film debuted the first one
was really big and when we first heard
about you know we're doing a sequel we
were like all right how are we gonna top
the first one but I think we did I think
that everything is bigger the sets the
the choreography the numbers all of it
is a really high energy and high stakes
and stuff like that so it's pretty it's
pretty funny
[Music]